Fanatee is a studio we started in 2013 introducing games with content,
especially word games, which we like a lot.
The most downloaded Fanatee game is STOP;
it has more than 10 million downloads on Android.
But today we have CodyCross, a game that was released in March of last year,
which we have grown considerably
and today already has more active users than STOP.
Android is growing a lot for us.
Today we get 75% of our downloads from Android.
We live in an Google play's environment where distribution is done for the entire world,
and it's therefore important that you develop apps that can be used by anyone.
In the case of the Fanatee games, location is extremely important.
The game has a local database, local content.
We practically make a game for each market.
We receive reviews from users in Canada who think our app was developed
there by local developers.
Because some questions were so close to their reality.
People don't think that a company in Brazil
can create quality content that is relatable to such a different country as Canada.
We released CodyCross in March of last year and in July we tested the subscription model.
We chose Germany and the United States for this test,
as these countries have a higher app purchasing rate.
Our subscription model gives you access to additional content,
this is its main benefit without watching ads.
And our in-app purchases are hints and power-ups in the game,
which means ultimately there is no cannibalization.
Our subscription revenue for CodyCross currently represents
between 15 and 20% of our total revenue in the countries where it is on offer.
We use some interesting tools like free trial, which is an important tool.
Someone can test the app for 7 days,
after which around 50% of people convert into subscribers.
Currently, around 80% of our subscribers began with a free trial.
CodyCross subscribers spend 50% more time in the game
and our retention of subscribers is up to 70% higher than other players.
Subscription brings in more predictable revenues
and this is very attractive for the entrepreneur, for the developer.
And it also gives you support as a revenue.
The main focus is to find an interesting
offer for the user that adds value and has a
cadence of content so the person remains motivated.
In addition, always communicate and release new content
so the user once subscribed, realizes that value is being created there.
The developer is concerned with increasing the amount of content or offerings.